mgk on fame suicidal thoughts and
marriage in his new documentary
i'm
yelling on the phone and like the
barrels in my mouth
megan's like dead silent speaking on the
truth for the last two years and i
didn't also want to
hide anything
an exclusive behind the scenes look at
lizzo's carpool karaoke her music is
kind of made for carpool karaoke hearing
her rap hearing her play the flu dancing
it was wonderful
selena gomez gushes over britney's
wedding i think it was a day for love
and i want
nothing more than happiness and burns
et's the download starts right now
[Music]
we start with machine gun kelly the
rocker is getting deep in his new
documentary opening up about his career
highs and lows last night's premiere in
new york doubled as date night for mgk
and megan fox who was calling all the
shots
[Music]
work this carpet megan
look at you in your crop top yeah yeah
it's pink your favorite color it's my
daughter's favorite color i think she
probably inspired that at me and now
machine gun kelly's 12 year old daughter
casey is taking center stage in his new
hulu dock life in pink streaming now i
feel like people have to dig deeper than
just like what they see on the internet
casey is such a bright young lady she
stole the dock to me now i gotta say i
did hear you say in the documentary you
call megan your wife a beautiful thing
that we get to go and share this with
the world with my wife i'm with my best
friend when did that happen it never
felt right calling on my girlfriend my
girlfriend seems too adolescent for the
like the depth of our relationship
are you so proud of this young man right
here i am i'm super proud
i'm curious do you guys have an official
wedding day
no he's on tour this year when it needs
to happen it'll open up the universe
will open it up and we'll do it
well they may not be married yet as we
see in the dog the couple of more than
two years have already been through
thick and thin he went through a very
difficult time when he considered taking
his own life megan went to bulgaria to
shoot a movie i called megan i was like
you aren't here for me i put the shotgun
in my mouth
and i go to [ __ ] the shotgun and the
shell just gets jammed megan's like dead
silent
you were on the receiving end of that
phone call how the two of you healed and
grown together we've done every form of
therapy that exists it's a constant
process of like suffering
and passion and love and the repeat
cycles and there's lots of all of those
things all of the time
stranger things storm wynonna ryder is
also opening up about what it's like
being trapped in the upside down of
hollywood she's on the cover of the july
issue of harper's bazaar and admits that
her highly publicized breakup with
johnny depp back in the 90s put her in a
dark place she calls it her girl
interrupted real life comparing that
time to the movie she starred in about a
woman who gets committed to a
psychiatric hospital you're not free
you need this place you need it to feel
alive
it's pathetic everybody goes through
really troubled lonely times in their
lives whether it's when they're
a teenager or when they're an adult
wynonna hinted that when she and johnny
were dating i just wasn't taking care of
myself they of course got engaged after
dating only a few months and broke up
after four years together depp's wynonna
forever tattoo was eventually changed
and it's something he spoke about
recently in his defamation case against
his other ex amber heard
i took off the last two letters
and had it say wino forever through
pain
comes hum i asked him about the tattoo
he has on his arm and
slapped me across the face
i'm certainly not
going to strike a woman
if
she decides to make fun of a tattoo that
i have on my body depp who was awarded
more than 10 million dollars in the case
is now in paris working on louis xv it's
his project his first one actually since
the trial wrapped four weeks ago
two more battle dexes will be heading to
court jason alexander was ordered by a
judge to face a trial for allegedly
stalking ex-wife britney spears on the
day of her wedding
so here's inside scoop guys
when jason alexander
jason was arrested after this live
stream which showed him raiding
britney's home on june 9. and at
yesterday's two-hour preliminary hearing
a member of spears's security team who
was fired after the incident revealed
jason attempted to break into her
bedroom too which was reportedly locked
tell me the truth
gotta have a gun
security also said jason was armed with
a box cutter brit and sam were granted a
three-year restraining order against him
earlier this month but he'll stay in
jail until the trial her lawyer has
vowed to e.t he'll make sure jason is
prosecuted to the fullest extent of the
law moving on to wendy williams the
former tv host is ready for her next
chapter and shedding light on her new
gig any new projects you're working on
now that your show's over uh podcast of
course okay which will make more money
for me than doing the tv show now wendy
of course has roots in radio so podcast
is a no-brainer and rumor has it she's
already working to line up some big
names so tmz is reporting she recently
spoke to snoop dogg fat joe the
kardashians and even a member of the
trump family about being guests this
news comes nearly two weeks after
comedian sherry shepherd hosted the
series finale of the wendy williams show
wendy was absent from her own show all
season while dealing with health and
financial issues sherry will be taking
over her time slot this fall
i got a confession to make go on this
thong is so far up my ass right now
okay it's breaking skin
damn i feel like oxygen just went back
to my brain
oh that is the liza we know and love
holding literally nothing back in a new
carpool karaoke with james corden
in a minute i'ma
in this segment she gushes over the
other female artist who has a song of
the summer beyonce when i
dropped out of college and i was really
depressed
i listened to b-day on repeat like i've
she's been my north star
yeah have you met her
no really i'm not friends with her i've
never met her should we call her
don't [ __ ] with me
oh are you joking there's no way i'm
only e.t spoke with james corden who
explained what lizzo was like behind the
scenes
[Applause]
we were the first show she was ever a
guest on i've always had a very good
relationship with her
anything surprise you during shooting
that if i'm honest no
because i felt like
she is
in every sense
always her authentic self
and you know there's nothing ryan
gosling can't do y'all the abs the
acting the hair the denim eva mendes
reacts to her real life ken in the new
barbie movie i feel like my man has
started a real renaissance like a
kenneth
that news tops tonight's talk show
circuit yeah that photo of ryan even
inspired co-host jerry o'connell to give
himself a little makeover gary o'connell
has to
embrace the look
oh my gosh what do you say will i feel
like we could maybe do a little
something
next show
well you know what in the meantime no we
have more new pics of ryan this time
with co-star margot robbie on set in
venice beach looking very bright neon
can't miss them especially in those
roller blades the movie due out next
summer also stars simulio america
ferreira kate mckinnon michael sarah
issa rae and comedian will ferrell who
was photographed on set for the first
time this week as well looking good all
right moving on to the kissing booth
three star excuse me kissing there's
somebody we can't keep up actress joey
king she revealed to chelsea handler
who's filling in for jimmy kimmel that
she's guilty of acting under the
influence on my last day of filming
kissing blue two and three
i took an edible
while we were still filming it's very
unprofessional and i got like so
violently high
i took it during the scene where me and
my best friend lee are on the boardwalk
having a heart-to-heart about why i lied
to him about college my god my
director's gonna find out tonight
because he did say to me he was like you
okay honey then that made me so paranoid
i was like oh my god everyone knows okay
so now we have to pull the receipts
right we have to re-watch that clip from
the movie let's see if we can tell
[Music]
ever there was a scene to do it i mean
she didn't talk
her super walk would have been much much
different uh we know joey is in wedding
planning mode she recently got engaged
to the act director stephen piatt so did
beanie feldstein wedding bells are
ringing y'all she made the announcement
last week with her longtime love bonnie
roberts turns out her mom gave an
award-worthy performance to pull off the
surprise my mom when i keep trying to
get her in the car because we're going
to be late
and she's like
i i think something's wrong with me i
was like is she gonna my rudolph and
bridesmaids
no it's happening it's happening she
pulls over in west la runs into a random
restaurant the first thing as an engaged
person that i whisper in bonzier is my
mama's my mom almost pooped on the side
of the road and she goes
it was all a lie to make sure you didn't
get here early and i was like
my mom deserves an offer
another love story we're watching is the
tale of harry styles and olivia wilde
check them out a few days ago in london
sharing a smooch no source tells e.t
that they're much more comfortable with
getting attention while in public adding
that privacy is still very important to
both of them but they also want to live
their lives authentically and that means
some pda and they better get ready for
questions because soon they'll be doing
press for their new movie don't worry
darling which hits theaters in september
always
you're me
you fell in love on a movie sir oh wow
how to answer this question i had a
wonderful experience being directed by
olivia and uh i really meant for kind of
a really nice experience working on that
movie you know olivia's ex jason sedakis
is also in london he's deep into filming
season three of ted lasso which is
potentially its last
i feel like a real coach when i'm like
you know when i have to tell folks we
can't look at season four when we're in
the middle of season three we can't
worry about the championships while
we're in the first round of the playoffs
you know we gotta take it one game at a
time
now back to some relationship goals tom
holland is showing some love to
girlfriend zendaya as she graces the
cover of vogue italia when zendaya
posted the stunning cover on instagram
tom dropped three little heart eye
emojis in the comments it just sounds
like they're just showed up
no tom talk inside the spread but the
euphoria star did open up about
connecting with her fans through her
roles telling the magazine they've been
able to heal and grow and learn and mend
parts of their own past and that to me
is invaluable it gives me purpose
zendaya also reflected on her the past
and her hopes for the future adding
without the women of the past especially
iconic black women who have done what
i've done before i wouldn't be able to
exist in this space
i hope i can be a part of paying that
forward i think it's great to have that
support and that love around you because
you need that you know this isn't an
easy easy job so it's good to have
that to to free you up from it meanwhile
chris pratt is admitting he cried over
the backlash he received after thanking
his wife catherine for their healthy
baby girl last fall so it's in the july
august issue of men's health chris is
recalling the click bait that came out
afterwards saying things like that's so
cringe-worthy i can't believe chris
pratt would thank her for a healthy
daughter when his first child was born
premature that's such a dig at his
ex-wife well his reaction my son's gonna
read that one day he's nine and it's
etched in digital stone it really
happened bothered me dude i cried about
it i was like i hate that these
blessings in my life are to the people
close to me a real burden and the hate
he gets for his faith turns out he's not
a religious person saying religion has
been oppressive as f for a long time
adding i've never actually been to
hillsong i don't know anyone from that
church now hillsong that he's talking
about has had high profile parishioners
like justin bieber and it also came
under fire in 2015 for homophobic
comments made by church executives now
when it comes to his career chris is on
a high starring in jurassic world
dominion and the terminalist hitting
prime video this friday but even as a
shredded action star chris loves his
treats i go to my mother-in-law's house
for sunday family dinner and i just go
crazy on the desserts and that's
everything from ice cream and cookies
cake pie
and i do about seven days worth of
damage and take about seven days to pay
that off and
get right into it and he shared his
other diet secret with e.t for me the
key is cut out booze if i cut out booze
that means i also cut out all the other
crap that comes with it which is like
food at two in the morning all right
from a guardian of the galaxy to
britney's avengers that is actually what
some have called the crew of ladies who
were on hand for brit's wedding earlier
this month yeah i had a chance to chat
with guest selena gomez who dished on
the pop star wedding day girl squad
strike a pose there's nothing to it what
was it like to be there with donatella
madonna drew barrymore and be there to
support brittany um i think it was a day
for love and i want nothing more than
happiness for i don't know i think it
was all the people that loved her and
that was all that matters okay we are
still loving all these memes of these
six ladies at fritz wedding but celine
is also part of another incredible squad
with her only murders in the building
co-stars steve martin and martin short
did they try to set you up with anybody
no
no we're very protective of her but but
you know most of the people we know are
dead we don't know anyone under 50.
these three power up their podcast once
again to hunt down bunny's killer in
season two streaming now on hulu you
know the bar's been lifted pretty high
working with these two who's cooler than
me
everyone power politics money
production on season four of the emmy
award-winning show succession is
officially underway and here's
everything we know so far the entire roy
family is back in action kiernan culkin
jeremy strong brian cox sarah snook alan
ruck matthew mcfadyen and nicholas braun
aka cousin greg himself
i merely wish to answer in the
affirmative fashion
in the new ten episode
season we'll see all the sale of logan
roy's way star royko to tech visionary
lucas matson move even closer which
means more family division and power
struggles
i have you beat you
morons
now the million-dollar question could
this season be the last we've got these
great writers and jesse our genius who
writes the whole show so in a way
it's their decision and we just live by
that decision if he decides there's more
to be got out of it then we'll do a
fifth season i don't think we'll do much
more than that
another famous family returning to the
small screen the sanderson sisters
disney plus just released this
frighteningly i can't even say it i'm so
excited frighteningly fun trailer for
hocus pocus 2 due out september 30th
[Music]
blink and you might have missed it but
that was all three oh geez sarah jessica
parker bette midler and kathy najimi who
are back wreaking havoc in salem the
movie also stars sam richardson who told
e.t in january he is still pinching
himself i'm an absolute
super fan of the original is so surreal
and incredible and then to work with the
ladies i i'm outside of myself when i'm
doing these scenes oh well singer lava's
also been making some magic in the music
studio how his battle with depression
and ocd inspired his new album and mama
chris giving quiet to the tipsy toast
for chloe's birthday you are the person
who
is always looking at the left last
sample
he sees the download we'll be right back
[Music]
cardi b's making a big announcement
guaranteed to have you saying
she's dropping a new song this friday
with kanye west and rapper lol dirk now
we can't tell you the name of it because
it's not safe for work but this insanely
sexy picture that she shared should give
you an idea this could be some ideas uh
this is cardi's first new single in two
years and it's too bad we're gonna have
to wait a little longer for the music
video to go with it though you know how
i usually do the most with the promo i
just don't feel like doing too much this
time around because i'm just
i'm just exhausted with everybody i'm so
tired of people not doing their job
correctly well you know who else has
some new music too loud yeah he's
telling denny all about his second album
and the secret to learning to love
himself
[Music]
that was the video for kids our born
stars the latest single from live off
his highly anticipated upcoming second
album and he joins me right now
congratulations thank you i'm stoked for
us because as fans we get to enjoy some
new music from yeah the new album is out
august 5th right so excited you said
three days before your birthday three
days before my birthday what a gift i
know i'm excited you should be uh let's
talk about the title track first though
all for nothing because i feel like that
song is all about kind of surrendering
to love but this was like about that
kind of stage where like okay like i'm
really falling and i have to just let go
and let it happen it almost feels like
it's so reflective of the album cover
right where you're just like all right
this is me surrendering right
[Music]
obviously you've also been such a huge
advocate of mental health and have
spoken out about your experiences
everyone has their situation growing up
around people and their family or
friends you know struggling with mental
health and i think as i got older and i
kind of experienced my own like personal
all-time low and i was diagnosed with
depression and ocd and also if i can
share it you know just with my audience
and on social media and stuff like maybe
other people will find bits and pieces
that they can relate to
[Music]
well let's talk about the new single out
now kids are born stars what was the
inspiration behind this track i think of
the song as like a trade between like me
finding my imagination again today as
you know like i'm 27 now but also kind
of like trying to give that little kid
version of me a little bit of confidence
[Music]
we spoke to you recently at wengotingo
which i didn't realize was your first
show this year yeah it was just so crazy
i'm really excited especially too
because i have like i feel like i have
two full albums of like new music to
tour so how do you put the set list
together i did post on my like instagram
just like you know what songs you guys
want to see so i did some of that and
actually like the songs that i naturally
was already choosing were a lot of the
[Music]
haley kyoko is joining the tour i mean
she's also putting out some amazing new
music too yeah how excited you guys kind
of like i don't know tour the world
together it's gonna it's gonna be sick
yeah i think it would be really sick if
we could you know maybe do some more
tour dates and stuff and um she's super
dope so for fans who haven't been to a
live show what are they in for a lot of
ener it's
hectic in a good way
[Applause]
so you've already collaborated with so
many amazing artists i mean troye sivan
bts julia michaels you told us that
wayne go tango your dream list is
coldplay and drake yeah does drake know
about the freestyle raffle if we go to
dinner i'm gonna order the sparkling
water oh my god
i actually met drake in passing at a
sushi restaurant oh my god i love it
yeah that i was so nervous yeah that
would be that would be so sexy to work
with drake someday there aren't any
collabs on this record right no collabs
okay and was that kind of like a
conscious decision yeah it was kind of i
mean part of it was just being you know
honestly by myself at home and then some
of it was like you know because this
album was very much about me trying to
get back in touch with like ari like the
kid inside of me
i was like i just need to kind of like
do this myself a little bit and kind of
feel that out well i'm excited
congratulations all for nothing is out
august 5th and his north american tour
kicks off august 11. happy birthday to
you by the way thank you i love it
now what would a birthday be without
your mom giving a little tipsy toast at
least that's what happens when you're a
kardashian i know i'm a little wasted
and a little green
but
what i want to say is how much i am so
in love with you
turned down for a while right chris's
boyfriend corey gamble tried to spare
her more embarrassment and move the
martini glass areas far
far away
here's the thing though the prom mom
attempted to finish her speech but all
she could manage was more mumbling lots
of love though and a few happy tears to
of course celebrate chloe's 38th
birthday look who hasn't given a two
drunk toast before i know i sir
i played the fifth on that all right
guys that's gonna do it for us make sure
to join us back here tomorrow for a new
episode of et's the download goodbye
[Music]